to do what you do
you have to think like
whoever the enemy and the the
opposition is meaning
if i'm gonna go out there and uh
go against the
dirty manipulative deceptive
tactics that are out there i almost have
to match them don't i because you know a
lot of times you'll talk from uh
you'll sit down and have conversations
with the left or the right
and the the the right will say
the left is just extremely manipulative
and what they do and they're willing to
go and play such dirty tricks and look
what they did in chicago with jfk and
dewey and bill they'll get the votes
they'll get this they'll get that
and then uh some people say well we have
to play their games against them to beat
them right
and then uh you'll have faith-based
folks will say we're just not gonna
cross the line that's not what we're
gonna do we're gonna stick to it
but i think there's a part of it where
you know the whole saying goes if you
want to wrestle if you wrestle with a
pig
you know you you kind of get some mud
yeah yeah but the point is if you're
going to wrestle with a pig you're going
to you have to have some kind of pick
tendencies you have to play their games
against them
did you ever in your mind say look
you guys all want to play square and you
want to play safe i'm going to go
against these guys and i'm going to use
their strategies against them i'm going
to piss them off was that kind of
a line you had to be willing to cross or
this is the line you're going to come as
close to the line as possible but not
cross it i don't know if you understand
the question i'm asking i understand i
understand what are your thoughts on
that well there was a professor in
college named david knowlton and he
introduced me to my name solinsky and
and david knowlton was i don't know if
he was a professor or an adjunct guy but
he was a businessman lobbyist who taught
a class and i took and
any any any this rules for radicals by
so lincoln if you've heard of this book
sure there's a line in this book it's
called rule number four make them live
up to their own book of rules
now that sounds sort of machiavellian
and twisted but it's just a simple it's
really another way of saying it is
expose their hypocrisy
so and olinsky says it i think he said
in this rules radical's book you know he
was talking about christians and it's
hard for them to live up to their own
standards it's hard for them to live up
to the bible for example but you can
apply that to anything
and i read that line in that book rules
for radicals
which is now transformed into something
just sort of journalistic but at the
time there was on campus they had these
uh
speech codes they called them you can't
offend anyone for any reason you know
you can't you can't say anyone that say
anything that offends anybody and for me
that was a slippery slope
i just viewed it as twisted i said you
can't offend anybody well the whole idea
of
college is to
is to exchange ideas so that's what led
to the lucky charms thing where i said
okay well if i can't offend anybody well
then why don't i say this box of lucky
charms is racist against my irish
heritage
and and it was i was like a form of
satire i guess or you know exposing it
but
now what what's what this is evolved in
is and i want to draw a boundary is it
absolutely not do we do what they do
we do not lie to our to the people we do
not deceive the audience we do not do
the things that they do we do
sometimes use deception in the sense of
a pretext with our subject in other
words
in journalism circumstances can arise in
which deceit towards the subject is less
wrong than other possible courses of
action including being so honest with
your subject such that you are dishonest
with your audience in other words if i
come to you let's say you work for the
pentagon and i say hi i'm a journalist
tell me all the fraud you're committing
and you give me some canned line and
then i publish your line to the millions
well now i'm lying to millions of people
but if i pretend to be a telephone
repair man and i'm in your office and
we're talking and i record you right and
you don't know it well i've just
lied to you about who i am but in doing
so i've gotten some truth which i
broadcast to the people and they'll
attack me o'keeffe's a liar he uses
deception and undercover i say it's a
question of relative deception
and and and in this business in
journalism you have a choice to make so
i it wasn't so much that i was obsessed
with
undercover and wanting to do this these
things that seemed manipulative
i we wanted to do whatever we needed to
do
to get to the truth we had to dig deep
we had to learn how to use disguise and
pretense and these things that were not
comfortable these are not comfortable
things to do
you don't like doing them in fact i
could tell you in that in that lucky
charms video
my heart was beating 160 beats per
minute
it didn't i didn't you know wasn't
comfortable
uh performing in this way to get to get
this information did it feel did it make
you feel like i feel like i'm being a
little bit deceptive and dirty or no
you're kind of like listen i'm gonna
match you
i'm gonna match you at this i'm not
gonna lie i'm not going to do this but
i'm going to play all the games
necessary to get as close to the line as
possible no it felt uncomfortable it
felt uncomfortable but the best i can
say is it felt uncomfortable but
necessary i remember confronting the
professors i had printed out these
certificates and you know this is all
irony and satire like
think of it like borat meets 60 minutes
that's the best way i can describe it it
was like borat okay i'm going to go in
there i'm going to pretend to be this so
i can expose the reaction and expose the
the the the speech policies i felt so
uncomfortable
i forced myself to do it i forced myself
to do it it's like
you know doing something you hate doing
frankly like i had to stick my little
child armed on a sewage pipe i i just
forced myself to do it because i said
this must happen i must do this so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]